[Música]
bom então como eu acho que dá pra
perceber eu sou meia japa
eu não tenho uma família japonesa por
parte de mãe
não sei se alguém aqui que é mais
japonês
ele é um povo que é frio é frio por
natureza não tem contato físico
as pessoas não se encostam é se você vai
abraçar o japonês é uma coisa quase
desconfortáveis e meio constrangedor
acho que eu te amo ou sei lá acho que
nunca houve
mas o jeito que japoneses têm para
mostrar que gosta é com a comida
o jeito que tem para demonstrar o afeto
para japonês é assim é na casa dos meus
avós e que mal eu gostava em mim é tudo
que eu queria comer eles me davam então
eu estava com vontade de comer alguma
coisa o meu vô trazia ele me dava ele
sentava na minha frente e comia comigo
sem muitas vezes abrir a boca e não
falava uma palavra mas era naquele
momento ali que ele tinha como mostrar
que ele gostava de mim de dar uma
conectada ali só dividir a comida ea
memória mais forte que eu tenho dele e
que não está mais aqui é com laranja e
com mixirica tiver coisa super simples
porque não é que ele me dava laranja
mexerica inteira eu parava na frente
dele e ele começava a descascar
eu ficava ali meio de notícia nada ele
conseguia descascá sem cortar casca
ficava que ela tira inteira num dia um
furo na parte branca ea mexerica não
tinha um negócio branco ele me dava
mixirica lisinha
então não é que era laranja ou a
mexicana que demonstrava o afeto dele o
feto não tava nisso o afeto estava no
serviço era o serviço que ele fazia que
transformava o ingrediente um produto em
afeto e era fazendo isso
pensando em mim que é comer que ele
compartilhava um pouco de quem ele era
comigo e aí depois de terapia a gente
gosta e eu adoro buscar o porquê das
coisas é não é por acaso que foi no
salão do restaurante e não na cozinha
que eu me achei a minha paixão está no
serviço é onde estão as pessoas onde
consegue interagir e conversar
agora imagina formado em gastronomia
chegar em casa e fala assim então você
garçonete
imagina a alegria das pessoas tem um
pouco de preconceito em cima disso na um
pouquinho é esse era o meu primeiro
emprego depois de formado em gastronomia
só que quem faz gastronomia raramente
que semetre que é o chefe do salon todo
mundo que faz a economia que é seu chefe
da cozinha né
aqui no brasil a gente carrega um
resquício de uma cultura escravocrata
muito pesada e isso dificulta bastante a
gente enxergar algumas funções como
profissões é difícil as pessoas
entenderem que eu escolhi fazer carreira
justamente no salão inclusive a palavra
serviço ela é uma palavra que vem do
latim e significa escravidão um escravo
o sonho seria na verdade de parar de
usar a palavra serviço pra falar de quem
está atendendo né
as pessoas quando fui pra comer elas
elogiam a comida elas elogiam a bebida
sair falando de tudo isso mas o
atendimento ele acaba ficando marginal
na cabeça das pessoas o atendimento eu
entendo que seja difícil de valorizar e
quando eu como pratos do chef eu consigo
falar que esse chefe é muito bom e eu
comia comida dele
agora o atendimento ele é abstrato
ele não é tangível mas ao mesmo tempo
ele é extremamente relevante porque por
mais abstrato que seja que cuida do
clima da casa eo clima não é concreto
é isso mexe de maneira muito muito
concreta no que a gente está sentindo
né quando a gente sai para comer
é a gente quem num restaurante e que a
gente vai no restaurante
já no restaurante que comer só comer
físico plataform fazer o estômago só
parar de roncar ou mais que isso
se fosse só a matar a fome porque eles
não comem a comida congelada a gente não
come qualquer coisa está bom mas quando
a gente vai no restaurante está buscando
um monte de outras coisas
além dessa forma física se alguém tem
dúvida disso
eles acham que alguém que gasta quatro
dígitos numa refeição tá lá pra comprar
sua comida
acho que não é o restaurante ele vende
muito mais do que coisas tangíveis e
concretas ante ele vende muito mais do
que alimento do que bebida
o restaurante ele vende tempo pra quem
está com pressa o restaurante dever de
informação um retorno de vem de cuidado
pois hora de vendê afeto e hoje em dia o
restaurante vende inclusive status de um
restaurante que chama eleva nedson
parque que fica em nova york ele já foi
eleito o melhor restaurante do planeta e
é uma das principais referências que a
gente tem em atendimento
quando você faz uma reserva não leva
madison e vai lá gastar os quatro
dígitos
eles mandam e mail pra você e perguntam
o que eles podem fazer por aquela
experiência se ainda mais especial
eu já atuei lá eles me contaram que teve
gente que respondeu que era um paciente
terminal e queria fazer a última
refeição da vida dele naquele
restaurante
então acho de fome no sentido mais raso
físico fisiológico não é disso que estou
falando é quando a gente está satisfeito
é que a gente tem o bastante
só que a gente ser humano a gente é
insaciável sempre a gente sempre vai ter
fome de novo a gente sempre vai ter um
novo sabor que a gente quer provar a
gente sempre vai ter uma nova carência
para suprir ea gente usa todos os nossos
sentidos pra buscar essa satisfação e
comer é uma coisa que é essencial
então a gente está buscando a satisfação
a gente comer porque é essencial a gente
não comer beber diz não fica vivo
agora imagina se a cada oportunidade que
a gente tiver de comer bebê se a cada
garfada cada gole foram jeito da gente
sente mais prazer e não é só o prazer
pelo paladar
não é só o prazer por sentir uma coisa
boa quando eu como alguma coisa que eu
gosto mas é um prazer simplesmente por
estar sendo bem tratado
imagina com leve e vai ficando a vida se
toda vez que eu comer beber alguma coisa
eu tiver prazer nisso e se tratar bem é
o que a gente chama de hospitalidade
porque hospitalidade
eu e as palavras é ela vem do hospital
de hospitaleiro que quem recebe
então quem está ali no ambiente de
hospitalidade é o grande anfitrião um é
quem está recebendo como se fosse a sua
própria casa e ninguém recebe em casa
acredito eu querendo maltratar alguém a
gente sempre quer tratar bem aliás como
dizem sangue não vira água e o conceito
que eu mais gosto de hospitalidade é o
japonês chama o motor e na china o motor
e nash significa você recebeu seu
convidado com todo o seu coração e que
aquele momento aquela pessoa é mais
importante do que você mesmo e essa
hospitalidade que a gente fala que agora
ela está aplicada restaurante
restaurante a gente fala o tempo inteiro
quase todo dia a gente fala de um
restaurante mas vocês já pararam para
pensar a origem do restaurante
o restaurante na verdade era um caldo
que era servido quer um caldo
restaurador restaurante vem de restaurar
o restaurante é o lugar onde as pessoas
entram para sair melhor do que quando
elas entraram
e é isso saber disso temos a consciência
que dá muito propósito e que dá muito
orgulho pra quem tá servindo a gente tá
ali servindo ao outro pelo bem estar do
outro pensando no outro só que está
muito longe de ser e está abaixo do
outro não existe hierarquia quando a
gente fala em serviço
porque se eu tenho consciência disso o
servir ele é uma via de mão dupla
ao mesmo tempo que está restaurando o
comensal eu estou valorizando o meu
trabalho
[Música]
pensando nisso não é só uma questão de
alimento
eu também tenho que pensar na qualidade
de vida da equipe e essa é hoje a alma
principal do meu trabalho de trás de
todo o treinamento de trás de toda a
informação técnica e tentar muito
preocupada com a qualidade de vida
comida da minha equipe
ninguém dá aquilo que não recebe não tem
como a equipe comer mal e serviços
incluindo o prato de quem vai comer não
tem como uma equipe que está maltratada
tratar bem e não tem como uma equipe que
não está vivendo feliz em conseguir
representar tudo isso que a gente está
falando aqui
o garçom ele é o grande mensageiro de um
restaurante o garçom ele é o
interlocutor
ele é o elo com o consumidor tudo o que
aconteceu antes de um prato ou de um
copo chegar até a mesa
l com o garçom que essa mensagem vai
chegar e não é só uma mensagem verbal
se eu entendo o valor daquilo que eu
participei do processo eu sei o que
aconteceu à minha postura para servir
esse alimento já vai ser diferente e aí
tem uma informação já virou e as
palavras de novo é que eu nunca mais
esqueci saber e sabor têm exatamente o
mesmo radical que significa ter gosto ou
seja quanto mais eu sei sobre alguma
coisa
mas gosto ela vai ter então se eu tenho
todo um trabalho da equipe de cozinha do
chef se vou procurar o melhor produtor
o pequeno produtor eu quero valorizar
nacional
tudo isso é muito legal mas só vai virar
muito sabor
se eu tiver junto o saber o saber é o
que a equipe do salão tem como
ferramenta para fazer vocês sentirem
mais sabor e é o saber que faz a equipe
do salão deixar de ser vista como alguém
que só carrega uma bandeja é muito mais
do que isso e aí também ligada à minha
história de vida é as bebidas são
grandes aliadas nesse processo
a gente hoje está falando de um monte de
bebida diferente a gente fala das
cervejas do jim o café tem um monge
preocupação com isso ea bebida ela tá na
mão da equipe do salon então a bebida
ela agora talvez seja ela que dê a
chance da equipe do salão mostrar ainda
mais o valor que tem
as bebidas elas muitas vezes elas chegam
prontas no restaurante ela vem dentro da
garrafa
mas eu tenho temperatura copo a extração
de um café
tudo isso é serviço então a bebida ela
materializa a qualidade do serviço
se até agora ainda estava meio abstrato
com bebida é puramente serviço
todo mundo aqui é ter uma referência de
uma boa refeição
[Música]
eu tenho certeza que em todas elas
o atendimento foi um fator relevante
duvido que alguém tenha uma referência
de uma refeição muito boa em que o
atendimento tenha sido muito ruim
só que a gente tem várias frentes para
trabalhar para mudar essa valorização
eu preciso mudar a cabeça do dono do
restaurante
eu preciso mudar a cabeça do cliente e
eu preciso mudar a cabeça de quem está
ali também atendendo que não têm noção
do valor que tem nesse contexto todo
da gastronomia se o dono enxergar a
minha equipe como os grandes mensageiros
como os grandes embaixadores de tudo o
que eu pensei desde o primeiro momento
eu quis abrir um restaurante não tem
como eu do outro valor para eles se o
cliente enxergo que quem me atende
não tá me dando só um prato em cima da
mesa
ele me dar conhecimento eliminar cuidado
ele me dar afeto
eu valorizo muito mais que entendendo
esse é o garçom se eu atendente enxergar
que todo mundo que veio até a mim veio
pra sair melhor do que quando chegou
eu mudo completamente o propósito e
orgulho que eu tenho do meu trabalho
o top ser humano a primeira coisa que
fez na vida foi comer né
e esse primeiro alimento que a gente
comeu ele não caiu de uma árvore
ele já veio de outra pessoa
então pra mim não tem jeito não tem como
a gente fugir disso o fator humano ele
vai ser sempre o melhor ingrediente em
nome de todo mundo acredita que a vida
isso muito obrigado
[Aplausos]